[APPLAUSE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: So my
name is Laurence Moroney.
My Chinese name is [INAUDIBLE].
And I come from Seattle,
and I work on Firebase,
and I work on a lot
of Google technologies
but primarily Firebase.
And today I'd like to
introduce Firebase to you
and talk about some of
the technologies that
are available in Firebase to
you as developers building
for international applications.
Now, Firebase, it's more
than just one product.
It's an entire suite of
products, and it's a strategy.
And the idea behind Firebase
is that we identified
that developers need a lot
more than just platform
APIs for building
applications, be it
for Android or iOS or the web.
A lot of developers are below
what we call the poverty line.
And that is their apps will make
less than $500 US per month.
About 10% to 15% of developers
are very, very successful,
making $2,500 or more per month.
And we took a look at what are
the attributes of those apps?
What do they do?
What are the habits
of these developers
who are very, very successful?
And some of the
things that we found
that these developers were
very successful at doing
are being able to effectively
do things such as notifications
to be able to retain their
users, cloud messaging
to be able to have interactivity
within their application,
some great authentication.
It's very, very difficult,
and it's very, very expensive
to build your own
authentication system.
So we saw that
successful developers
were using third-party
authentication systems
and allowing people to
reuse their existing social
identities within
these successful apps.
We saw that very successful
developers were targeting
more than one platform.
The top developers all target
Android, iOS, and the web.
So we wanted to build
a suite of technologies
and a suite of services
that treat all three
of these equally.
So you as a developer, in
order to be successful,
we didn't want you just to
be an Android developer,
we would like you to be an
Android and iOS and a web
developer also.
And we group all of
these technologies
into three families,
the first of this family
are things that I call
supporting developers,
technologies that
make your experience
as a developer better.
And that's the ones on the
left-hand side of the diagram
here.
And I'm going to go into
each of these in detail.
But beyond developing,
we also realized
that people need
great technologies
and great techniques
that will allow
them to grow their application.
It's not enough for you to
solely market your application.
Most applications grow, for
example, by word of mouth.
People teach people
about great apps.
So we wanted to make
that easy for you,
and we wanted to build
a technology that
would make that easy for you.
And then, of course, the most
important probably is earning.
You want to be able to earn
money from building your apps.
You want to earn money
from all of your hard work.
And we've been working
on technologies
to make that better.
But all of these are bound
together by analytics.
And at the heart-- and that's
why it's right in the center
of this diagram--
at the heart of
Firebase is analytics.
So let me talk a little
about analytics first.
You may have heard
of Google Analytics.
Well, Firebase Analytics was
built by the same people,
but we built it from the ground
up to optimize it for apps.
We wanted to make it
event- and user-centric
so that as you're
building an application,
you don't have to
worry about analytics,
that they are things that are
being collected automatically
for you, should you want them.
Now, I've spent many years
working as a developer
and working as a
developer manager.
And I've been to way
too many meetings,
and I'm sure many of you have,
where you sit around the table
and as the developers are there,
the marketing people are there,
the architects are there, the
business people are there.
And you're talking
about requirements.
And then the requirement
for analytics comes up.
And the developers want
one set of analytics,
the business people want
another set of analytics,
the marketing people want
the social people want
another set of analytics.
And in the end, you
compromise by saying
we're going to do them all.
And then the developer manager
says we can't do them all,
because we don't have the time.
How many people have
been in that situation?
Quite a few.
So with that in mind, when
we built Google Analytics
and when we built Firebase
Analytics in particular,
we wanted to make it
really easy for developers
to be able to build the most
common analytics directly
into their app without
writing any code.
So if we get into
that circumstance
where these people are all
sitting around the table
asking about the
types of analytics
that they want, all of the
common things that you would
expect in an app-- app
opening, app closing,
migrating between screens,
app being installed, app
being uninstalled, all
of these common events
are actually captured
for you without you
writing any code whatsoever.
There's a library that you
link into your application,
and you're done.
Now, I love to live by the 80/20
rule, where 80% of the things
are usually what
everybody wants.
And I would say that
this, by the 80/20 rule,
80% of the analytics
that you want to capture
are going to be captured
for you in that way.
But of course, there
are custom analytics
that you want to capture too
that we don't know about.
Say you've built a
game, and you want
to know how many people are
beating the big boss on level
three.
Well, we can't predict that.
We don't know about that.
That's your game,
that's your domain.
So as a result, of course,
by writing some code,
you can then collect
those analytics also.
You're not just limited
to the analytics
that we're giving you for free.
And that's the idea
behind Firebase Analytics.
And it's one of the themes that
you'll see throughout Firebase
as I talk about it.
And we really wanted
to make life as easy
as possible for developers.
But if you want to go
beyond what we're giving you
in the product, we're making it
as easy as we can to extend it.
And here's an example of what an
analytics dashboard in Firebase
looks like.
So a Googler built a game called
Bingo Blast that he put out
in the Play Store.
And he got a number
of users using it.
And the idea is that
we wanted to show off
what the analytics
looks like at Google IO.
So I took this screen
capture of the console
so that you can start seeing
some of the analytics that
were collected.
And remember, this
was the free analytics
that he did not write
any code for whatsoever.
And when I say
analytics are free,
I also mean they're
free money-wise too.
You don't have to pay anything.
They're completely unlimited.
They're free, and it's at
no cost to you whatsoever.
So here's an example of
some of the analytics.
And if you look
closely, you can see
on each of these
tiles on the top left,
there's a little Android
icon on a couple of them,
and there's a little blue
iOS icon on a couple of them.
And here are some of the things
that he was able to collect.
So for example, he has
in-app purchases in his game,
and if we take a
look at, for example,
the com dot redhot labs
dot bingo application,
in the month before I captured
this, he had 22,000 users.
And the in-app purchases
from these users
was about $2,000 US.
So this app is doing
really, really well.
And if we look on
the right here,
the iOS one, he had
5,300 users, and he had
$30,000 in in-app purchases.
So one of the
things I was saying,
some of the habits of
highly successful developers
is that they're reaching
multiple platforms.
And as we can see here,
even though this person who
wrote this was from Google,
he wrote it for Android
and then he used Firebase, and
he also moved it over to iOS.
You can see that he was very,
very successful in doing so.
He was making a lot of dollars.
Some of the other
analytics that I collected,
as you can see at
the bottom here,
and I'll talk a little bit later
in the presentation about it,
is also crash reports.
So as your application
crashes, it's
one of the things that gets
really, really bad reviews.
And we built crash reporting
directly into Firebase
so that when an
application crashes,
you'll get this stack reading--
the stack overflow effectively
reading of your application
so that you can debug it
even if the person who
bought your application,
who had the crash,
is living on the other
side of the world.
And these are some of the
things that we see here,
that in his application
he had a number of errors,
like he had 9,000 errors in the
iOS one, impacting 2,000 users.
By using the
Firebase console, he
was able to go in to see
what those errors were
without contacting
the users directly.
So he could fix
them and redeploy.
So that's a sneak peek at
what's available in Analytics.
We do have an Analytics
session later today.
I advise you to come along and
see some of the great things
that you can do with
Firebase Analytics.
But now I want to talk
about the developer
technology, the things that
were on the left of my diagram
earlier on.
So there are a number
of back-end services
that we provide that will allow
you to build better apps as
well as app quality
services for things
such as the crash
reporting I mentioned
as well as the test
lab for Android.
The first of these is
the realtime database.
So the idea behind the
realtime database in Firebase
is to allow you to effectively
build codeless middleware.
Now, I've been a web developer
and a cloud developer
for a long time.
And web and cloud are really,
really great technologies,
but a lot of the time, if I just
want to build something simple,
if I want to build
something that
has a database and
CRUD operations,
so create, retrieve, update,
and delete, that's a lot of code
that I have to
write on a server--
or on a cloud server--
just to do this.
The idea behind the realtime
database in Firebase
is that you don't
write any of that.
You only write code that runs
in your client's application.
And this gives
you realtime data.
So it's a cloud-hosted,
no-SQL, database.
And one of the magical
things that it does
is the synchronization
and conflict resolution
between different
instances of an app.
So we all live in a
multi-device world.
We all have at least one
phone, and we have tablets,
and maybe we also are using
browsers, either on the phones
or on our laptops as well.
So if you have
built an application
where you have data that
a person, for example,
is updating on the
back-end database,
you want that update
to be reflected
across all of their devices.
It's a lot of code
you have to write.
That's a lot of maintenance
that you would normally
have to write.
But the idea behind the
Firebase realtime database
is it does all of that for you.
It's an event-driven database
that you access directly
from your app.
If you're used to writing
SQL-type applications,
as I was before I
discovered Firebase,
you think about those
are a pull model, where
you write a piece of SQL that
pulls data from a database,
and you have to fan it out
across all of your users.
The realtime
database in Firebase
is an event-based database.
So whenever a change occurs
within the data in the database
that you subscribe to, you will
get an update sent directly
to you that's an event that
fires in your application
that you can then respond to.
And this is an
example that I just
did an animation of showing
what I was talking about.
The user in the center
here on the laptop
made a change to the database,
and the Firebase infrastructure
fans that out, sends
that event to all
of the other devices
in that user's universe
and will update, if you
as it developer choose to,
of course, because you're
just receiving that event.
It's up to you how
to handle that event.
And you can update
the state of the UI
or you can update
data accordingly.
It's pretty cool stuff, and
I find it really exciting
to develop with because,
for me as a developer,
I've been working on a game
that it's made me so much more
productive not to worry about
writing a lot of code that runs
on a server and maintaining all
of that server infrastructure.
I just designed my
realtime database.
I designed it on the
Firebase console,
and then I just write code
that runs on my client.
And I've only got one place
to worry about writing code.
One of the other things
that it also does
is, it handles a
disconnected state.
So for example, if
you have a user that
has two devices and
Device A updates
the data and Device
B is offline,
what happens when Device B comes
back online is that Firebase
will actually notify Device
B that a change has happened
to this data so
that Device B can
update its app automatically.
It's really, really
neat, and it's no code
that you have to write.
Again, that's one of
the themes of Firebase.
It is one of the things
that makes me personally so
excited about Firebase is that
a lot of these common scenarios,
that would usually involve
you writing a lot of code,
doing a lot of debugging,
doing a lot of servicing,
are things that are
handled for you and things
that we've done for you as
part of building Firebase.
So next is Firebase
authentication.
And I just noticed that
they got rid of the English
on these slides, so
I'm going by memory.
And so if I get any of
these bullet points wrong,
you're going to have
to correct me, OK?
So the idea behind
Firebase authentication
is that one of
the most difficult
and one of the most
expensive parts of building
any application is building
a secure infrastructure
for your users identity.
You've probably
all heard stories
of places that have been
hacked and users' information
has been stolen.
And because of poor
security, because of things
that were written badly, because
of maybe social issues where
an employee let
passwords out and stuff
like that when he was
let go with a company,
these kind of things.
And for you to build
your applications,
it's a massive
investment for you
to build a secure infrastructure
for your users' identity.
So with that in mind, we
built Firebase Authentication.
With Firebase Authentication
being a federated identity
service so that if
users have identities
on places like
GitHub or Facebook
or Twitter or
Google and new ones
that we're adding all
the time, then the idea
is that they can
use that directly
within your application.
You're writing a
little bit of code
to hook up the button to
whatever the back-end service
is going to be,
and then they can
access their Firebase
back-end data
using that identity
instead of them needing
yet another identity to sign
up for your application.
And one of the other
reasons that we've
been building this is that we've
learned from developers that
building a user interface
to let somebody sign up,
to enter all their details,
to get a confirmation mail,
to handle that confirmation
mail, to move forward,
all of that user flow to sign
somebody up to use your app,
loses a lot of users.
People just want to use their
existing social identities,
so we've built that
in to Firebase.
We've also made an open
source, completely extensible,
back end for this so that
you can download from GitHub,
and you can start building your
own identities on top of this
if you so desired.
And one of the others that
I didn't mention, of course,
is if you just want a simple
username email-type identity,
that's built into the
structure for you also.
Did I get all of the bullets?
I see some nodding heads.
OK, good.
So next up is hosting.
And this one actually surprised
me in how powerful it is
and how useful it is,
because if you've ever
deployed an app
to the Play Store
or to the Apple's App
Store, you generally
need a website
associated with that app.
Now, sometimes the website might
be just something very simple,
a couple of
screenshots of the app,
contact details, support
links, those type of things.
But think about all that's
involved in doing that.
Right?
You need to get a domain name.
You need to hire webspace.
You need to build maybe
PHP or some static HTML
or whatever it is.
And it's a whole extra effort
for you to build and maintain.
Funny story-- I'm going to be
doing a demo this afternoon
on Cloud Messaging on a
website that I own and I built.
And yesterday--
I'm sorry, the day
before yesterday--
my billing on that website
actually expired and broke
my demo.
Because it's work
that I have to do
to maintain the billing on
that, to maintain the domain
name on that, I frantically
had to get my billing redone
for that website, to
repay for that website
so that I could
do the demo today.
That's work that I shouldn't
have to do as a developer.
That's all that extra
infrastructure stuff that,
as a developer, that if
I could make that easier,
it will allow me to
focus on writing my code
and on building better apps.
So the idea behind
Firebase Hosting
is that as part of
your Firebase Console,
you've got the ability to
surf basic simple websites,
static websites.
So HTML, JavaScript, all of
those kind of those things,
obviously images.
It's secure socket
layer by default.
And you can [? map a ?]
[INAUDIBLE] domain to it.
So it never takes
away the requirement
of you having to build
and maintain a website,
but it makes it a
whole lot easier.
And because it's
done in Firebase,
it's free as part of your
Firebase subscription.
And so there are different price
tiers of Firebase subscription,
but this is one of the ones
that's in the free tier.
So next up is Firebase Storage.
So this takes it a
little bit further,
where if you are building an
application that requires you
to store data on
your users' behalf,
maybe you're building a
photo sharing application,
video sharing application.
And you need to be able to store
files on your users' behalf,
and maybe your users will
be sharing those files
with each other, the idea
is that Firebase Storage
will do that for you.
Now, of course, you could
have your own storage system.
There's no reason why
you wouldn't do that,
but think about a
scenario of you're
building an application
that maybe manages videos
on behalf of your users, and
videos can get pretty big.
Now, if user A shares a
video with user B, and user B
wants to download
that video, what
happens if they
lose connectivity
during that download?
If you were building your own
system, you as a developer
would have to
write code and have
to write your infrastructure
to be able to manage handling
that download if the
connectivity goes down,
and then you can resume
later on halfway through,
those type of things.
But with Firebase Storage,
we put in that code for you.
We've done that type
of thing for you.
All of the quality
services that you
would expect from a cloud-based
infrastructure for managing
files have been built
into Firebase for you.
Next up is one of my favorites.
And I have a talk this
afternoon about this.
And this is Firebase
Cloud Messaging.
Now Firebase Cloud Messaging
is a cross-platform, no-cost
solution for realtime messaging.
We've measured that connected
devices will generally
receive--
something like 95%
of connected devices
will generally
receive the message
in less than 500 milliseconds.
And we are actually
reaching a point
now where we're serving over
a trillion messages per week
on this.
It's free for you to use
if you want to do so.
The idea is notifications are a
great to drive user retention.
Notifications are a great way
to drive user interaction.
And by building this
infrastructure that
will allow you to do
realtime notifications,
or close to realtime,
notifications
at no cost to you,
we think you've
got something that will really
help you to build winning apps.
Now messages can be targeted
in a number of different ways.
So for example, when a user
signs onto a Firebase app,
and that Firebase registers
itself with Cloud Messaging,
the device gets registered with
Cloud Messaging, not the user.
We have no details on
the user's information.
The user's information
is private,
but the device itself will be
registered with Cloud Messaging
so that we know the
address of that device
so that messages
can be sent to that.
Now, once you have
that device ID,
you can send messages
to a single device,
that device could be subscribed
to a group of related devices.
You could send to that group.
The device can
subscribe to something
that we call topics, where the
idea is that you as a developer
can build a topic.
And an example I
always like to use
is for example, an
application that
tells you about airport delays.
So we're in Beijing right now.
And if you were building an
application for your users
that tells you about
the status of flights
in and out of
Beijing, and if there
is a delay to your flight,
you could set a topic
for Beijing Airport
and to send only
to users that have subscribed
to that topic, notifications
about Beijing Airport.
Now, I live in Seattle,
and I don't particularly
want to receive notifications
about Beijing when I'm at home.
I do want to receive
them when I'm here.
So as a developer, for
somebody who's in Seattle,
you could have a
topic for Seattle
so that notifications
about delays or status
of Seattle Airport could only
be sent to that end user.
All you have to do as
a developer is set up
the notifications,
provide the user interface
to your end users about what
topics are available to them.
And when the end user
picks a topic, then
when you send
messages to the topic,
only that user will get those.
It's really powerful.
It's really cool stuff.
And when you add
analytics on top of that,
you could make it
really interesting.
So that you could
say only users who
have been online in the last
30 days should receive it.
Or only users in a particular
time zone should receive it.
You don't want to
receive a notification
for London Heathrow
Airport, for example,
in the middle of your night.
So you can add analytics
on top of all of this
to be able to drive message
targeting to make it really,
really smart.
Messages are very powerful.
But if they're used
incorrectly, they
can also be very obnoxious.
So you don't want to
turn off your users.
And as a result, we're
providing the tools
to allow you to be very
versatile about how
you use messaging.
I'm going to be showing a demo
of Google Cloud Messaging,
the server that I spoke
about that I built earlier on
is using that.
So if you come back
this afternoon,
I can show you how it all works.
My other personal
favorite is Remote Config.
And this one takes a
little bit of a moment
to get your head around what's
possible with Remote Config.
Now, the idea
behind Remote Config
is that it's server side
variables instead of the client
side variables.
So you can build
your application
to be decoupled completely
from server side--
from variables-- by putting
them on the server side
and then driving their
content off of analytics.
Let me give you an
example of this.
The game that I mentioned
that I've been working on
that I've been writing, it
involves you interacting
with a virtual character.
And this virtual character
in the first version
of the game that I built is
it's an animated character,
and she speaks English,
because I speak English.
And I've been adapting
this game for other markets
so that I built a version of it
for the Japanese market where
the character speaks
Japanese, and another one
for the Korean market
where she speaks Korean.
And I'm going to have to build
one for the Chinese market
soon, where she
would speak Chinese.
But what I've been able to do
with this application using
Remote Config was a number
of different things.
First of all, if
the user prefers
English as their language,
regardless of where they live,
they could receive
the English character.
So all I have to do is
set for that specific user
the language on a
server side variable.
And as a result, instead of
me modifying the application,
I could just give
them the character
that they want in the
language that they prefer.
Another example
of this is that--
so the application
itself uses geolocation.
So that if I'm--
it's a game that you play
in a number of locations
in the real world.
And so using geolocation
and using Google's APIs
for geolocation, you have an
API key that you need to use.
If I deploy that
API key in my app,
somebody could decompile
that application
and pull out the
API key, and then
maybe provide some kind of
denial of service for me
for the location services
by hammering on that API key
and overloading it so that
it wouldn't work for me.
But if I use Remote Config, I
put that API key in a Remote
Config, I now no longer
ship it with my application,
so now as a user is
running my application,
they read the API key
out of Remote Config,
and they get the API
key data, and they're
good to go with whatever
they need to do.
And if somebody does something
so that my API key no longer
works, all I have to
do is change it once
on the server in these
server side variables,
and then the users will get
a new API key going forward,
because they're reading
it from the server.
There are so many
different ways that you
can do things with this.
It's a very simple but
very powerful technology.
And some of the scenarios
that become available to you
by using Remote Config, by using
server side variables to change
the behavior of your application
without you actually writing
code of deploying new
versions of your application
are really cool.
I'll give one more,
and that is if you're
writing an eCommerce
application, for example.
And you could say, for example,
provide a discount that, hey, I
love people in China.
So I'm going to give them a
10% discount on everything
they buy in my
eCommerce application,
whereas people in the
USA, I'm only going
to give them a 5% discount.
The idea is, with
analytics, I can then
use an analytic that
says if user is in China,
set this variable to 10.
If user is in USA, set it
to 5, otherwise set it to--
I don't know, 3, something
along those lines.
So then the application,
triggered by analytics,
will be able to read
that value and give me
different discount amounts
in those different countries.
I could add another
layer on top of this,
then say, hey, if
it's December--
we're coming up to
the Christmas period--
that's double the discount.
You know, so then China would
get 20, USA would get 10,
and everybody else would get 6.
All these kind of things become
possible by having variables
stored on the server side.
You don't write any code to
manage them in the server,
and you just read them
using the Firebase Remote
Config on the client side.
And when you layer
analytics on top of it,
there are lots of fun
things you can do.
So the next one is
Test Lab for Android.
And one of the things that we
learned about this since we've
been working on
it is that Android
is a very, very
diverse operating
system with so many
different phones,
with so many different flavors,
with so many different form
factors, the screen resolutions,
those type of things
in Android devices.
And often, if you're a
developer, particularly
if you're a small developer,
maybe you're in China,
and you want to test on a
phone that's available only
in the US.
Let me give an example.
How many of you are
Android developers here?
OK.
Quite a few.
Keep your hands up if
you have a Google Pixel.
None.
Neither do I. Right?
But if I want to build and
test it on a Google Pixel,
I don't have a Pixel.
You don't have a Pixel.
And what happens
when the Pixel 2
or whatever the next version is
going to be called comes out?
It might take a while
before you get one,
but you want to be
able to test on that.
And that's the idea
behind the Test Lab
for Android is that
it's hosted by Google.
And it's a way that you could
upload your APK to Google
and have Google test it for
you on a variety of devices,
most of which you probably
don't have, many of which
may not be available
in your country.
And think about just all of
the work and money and expense
that you have to do to
maintain a test bed of all
these different devices,
with new ones coming out
daily and new features
coming out daily.
It's a nightmare to be
able to maintain that.
So what we do is we have
a number of devices,
some virtual, some physical,
in our data centers.
We upload your APK to them,
we do the test for you,
and there's a number of what
we call robotests, which
are standard tests
like open, close,
touch this, touch that, those
type of things, swipe left,
swipe right.
And then there are custom
tests that you can actually
define a custom test that says
enter this user's details,
press this button, go here, go
there, those type of things,
to get the response.
And then we'll give you
reports of what happened,
and we'll give you
screenshots of what happened.
So the idea is to take
all the of that burden
and all of that expense
and all of that difficulty
and complexity of testing on
diverse devices away from you
and give you this service
on which to do it.
Crash Reporting I
mentioned earlier on,
and the number-one
reason why people
get negative reviews
of their apps
in Play Store and the App Store
is because the app crashed.
Earlier I mentioned
I was writing a game,
and when I first sent
a copy of the game
to some people in Korea
to test the game for me,
it crashed every time.
And I had no idea why it crashed
every time, because I was using
Remote Configs to pretend I
was in Korea so that I could
get the Korean
character, and she
was talking to me in Korean.
I didn't understand
a word of it,
but I knew that it was working,
but when I sent it to people
in Korea, it was crashing.
I didn't know why
it was crashing,
and it turned out that I
had some bugs in my code
that for checking
the network, there
was some difference in checking
the network in Korea than I had
in checking my home Wi-Fi.
And as a result, it was
trying to download videos
that it couldn't actually
see and it crashed.
And using Crash Reporting,
I was able to see this.
I couldn't call the
person, because--
well, I could call the person,
but when I asked her, well,
what happened?
She said I opened the app and
said, you know, the app failed.
And that was it.
That was the only
data that she had.
And that is typically the
only data that users have.
But when I could go
into Crash Reporting,
I could actually see, and
I could see a stack trace.
And then from that stack trace,
I could tell what went wrong
and how to fix it.
And I was able to fix it
and ship a new version
without getting on a plane and
going to Korea to figure out
why it was failing.
And that's the real
power of Crash Reporting.
It will allow you to see
why things went wrong.
You don't have to wait
for somebody to call you,
that you can see the crashes.
If you remember already what
I showed in the Console,
you could see that this person
had had some crashes, and you
could go into the Firebase
Console, who's getting crashes,
where are the crashes happening,
why are they happening,
and getting a
stack trace of that
so you can fix it and
push out a new version.
And it's a great way also
to use notifications,
because then you can push
a notification to say,
hey, we're going to ship
a new version because
of crashing XYZ.
And again, this is all
integrated with analytics.
So you could use
analytics, for example,
to filter the
crashes to say, OK,
show me why people with
a particular device
in a particular place are
crashing so that you can group
them together and figure
out and just really
do a deep dive
into understanding
why your application
may be failing.
So those are the
technologies for developing
and for building on top of the
Android APIs and the iOS APIs
to help you to
build better apps.
But beyond building apps, you
also want to grow your apps.
You want to grow your business.
So the first of these is
what we call App Invites.
Now, I have an awesome
15-year-old son-- oop, sorry,
he just turned 16.
I have an awesome
16-year-old son.
And what he does is he
goes into the Play Store,
and he downloads lots and
lots and lots of games.
And he plays these games
for two or three minutes,
and then he either throws
them away or he keeps them.
And the ones that he
keeps, he tells me about so
that I don't have to spend
all this time downlaoding
these games, and I
discover some great fun
games because of my son.
Now, we realize
that not everybody
has an awesome
16-year-old son like I do,
so what we wanted to do
was make it really easy
so that if somebody is playing
your game or playing your app
and they want to share that
with people that they care about
or that they would like
to discover this app,
we wanted to make that easy for
you so we built App Invites.
Now, App Invites, it
allowed this-- like my son
was using your app and your app
had App Invites built into it,
then he could share it by SMS
or he can share it via email.
But what makes App
Invites really smart
is that we put some AI into
this so that what it does is,
it looks at the type of
application that he's sharing,
and it looks at
the type of person
who generally likes that.
And it sorts the
contact list that way.
So for example, almost every
time he shares a game with me--
I know it's going to be a good
game, I'm going to install it,
so I'm going to be at
the top of the list.
It's not alphabetically
sorted or anything like that.
It's got this
intelligence behind it.
And his mom, who says he
plays way too many games
and never installs
any that he sends her,
is going to be at the
bottom of the list.
So that's the idea
behind App Invites.
You get the intelligence of
the list being sorted according
to the people who are
most likely to really want
to see this engagement.
And as a result,
that prevents spam.
That prevents
spammy-type invites,
and it makes the
overall experience
with the person
sharing and the person
receiving stuff like that.
Now, this is built
on a technology
called Dynamic Links.
Now, Dynamic Links are
basically just URLs,
but they're URLs that maintain
context throughout a session.
Now, that sounds really complex.
So let me give an example
of how these work.
So I like to eat, as
you can probably tell.
And say, for example, I have
a recipe app on my phone.
And I find a recipe
for something
that I really, really like,
and what's going to happen?
I'm a terrible cook, but
my wife is a terrific cook.
My wife is Chinese, so of
course she's a terrific cook.
And so what happens
is I'll call her up,
and I'll say, hey, Rebecca, I
found a recipe in a recipe app
for, yeah, some
really great won ton.
Do you want to take a look?
And then she'll go to the app
store, and she'll take a look
and I'll say yeah, no.
It's the recipe app--
R-E-C-I-P-E-- yeah.
A-P-P. Yeah?
OK, you found it?
There's 500 recipe
apps in the store.
Oh, it's the one with
the carrot as an icon.
OK.
You found it.
Then she finds it,
and what happens?
She tries to download it.
Prior to download it,
she has to sign in.
She signs in, she
gets to the app.
She downloads the app.
By then, I've forgotten
what the recipe was.
I forgot what it was
that I'm looking at.
There's so much
friction involved.
So with Dynamic Links, the
goal that we've been doing
is that if I were to have that
app open, and I would share
with her this particular recipe
within that app, when she
receives that link, if she has
the app already in her phone,
then by pressing on that
link, it would launch and take
her directly to that recipe.
If she doesn't have
the app on her phone,
by pressing on that
link, it would take her
to the app store with
the correct listing.
Like I said, there's
hundreds of recipe apps.
And after installing the app,
it would remember and take her
all the way to that
recipe so that she
could read that recipe.
That's the intelligence that's
built into Dynamic Links.
We've also been working
on Google AdWords.
So Google AdWords are a
way that you can share
your app with other users.
So the idea is that
you can share your app
with other users who are app
users, who are people watching
on YouTube, who are people
searching on Google, all
of these type of things that
if you subscribe to an AdWord
for your application, it's going
to be smart enough to share it
with users who are relevant
for that type of application.
So for example, I love sports.
And whenever I'm searching
Google or watching YouTube
or using applications,
they're sports related.
So if you are building a sports
app, your ads that you've done
are much more likely to
reach me than my wife who
does not like sports.
So your spend on ads is
intelligently filtered
so that you're reaching
the right users.
Another one of my
favorites is App Indexing.
Now, App Indexing-- the
idea behind App Indexing,
is that you can discover your
application through a Google
search based on the content
of that application.
So if I give an example of--
I used sports a moment ago--
I love ice hockey.
It's one of my favorite sports.
And whenever I want
to take a look at how
my local team or my
favorite teams are doing,
I usually go to Google
Search and I search for it,
and I'm taken to a webpage or
I'm taken to a list of webpages
and maybe find one
of those webpages
to see the score of my
local ice hockey teams.
But I have an app from that
team that I've installed
and I've forgotten about.
You know, this app
doesn't use app indexing.
I'm asking them to use it,
because what would happen
is if you build the app, and
the app is on the user's device,
the user has already told you
that they love your content,
because they've installed
it on their device--
the app-- and they've kept it.
They haven't gotten rid of it.
So now in future,
if they're searching
for that type of content
using the Google Search app,
the idea is why take
them somewhere else that
might be something that they
like when they've already
said they like it in this app?
And that's the idea
of App Indexing.
So when you search for something
using Google, using the Google
Search app, you can be taken
to apps as well as sites.
And in many ways,
you're probably
going to prefer to
be taken to apps
because you've already
installed them.
You've already made an
investment in those apps.
One thing that we've
recently released
is also personal content.
So if you have personal
content on your phone--
so for example, you
have a note-taking app,
and as well as loving hockey,
I manage a youth hockey team.
And I keep notes about
all of their games
in a note-taking app.
Now the idea is that the
personal content is also
indexed for me.
So sometimes when I'm searching
for details about hockey,
I can be taken into
my own personal notes
that I might have made
and forgotten about.
It's really, really cool stuff.
And it's a great way of
re-engaging with your users.
How many times have
you built an app,
you've put it out
into the market,
you've done advertising
for that app, you've done,
you've marketing for
that app, you've gotten
lots and lots of installs.
And then suddenly
the installs dry off.
And then you see-- if you're
using Analytics-- you see
people uninstalling your app.
And you don't have
marketing budget
to continue to re-market it.
That's one of the ideas
behind App Indexing,
because people are always
searching using their phones.
And if they're searching
using their phones,
and they like the content
that's in your app,
they should be
re-discovering your app.
And that's why we
built App Indexing.
Notifications is related
to Cloud Messaging
that I spoke about earlier on.
But the idea behind this
one is that this again
is a no-programming interface.
So instead of a lot of the
stuff, the features that I
was talking about, like the
versatile targeting, now
with a Firebase Console--
and I'll demo this
again this afternoon--
one of your marketing
people or something
like that can get
into the Console,
use Analytics to
pick an audience,
and then send a notification
directly to that audience.
And then that audience
can be re-engaged straight
back into your application.
It's very, very easy.
It's very, very straightforward.
And if you want to use real-time
notifications in your app,
but you don't want to build
Google Cloud Messaging,
this is another option for you.
It's built on top
of Cloud Messaging.
It's using all the
features and the technology
that I spoke about
earlier on, how
it gives you the fast messaging,
the reliable messaging
delivery.
Finally, on earning money,
just AdMob by Google
you may be familiar
with already.
It's the other
side of the adverts
that I was speaking
about earlier on.
In this case, instead of you
buying adverts and having
the correct-- those
adverts delivered
to the correct population
that would receive them,
this is if you put
adverts into your app
to make sure that the adverts
match the population that's
using your app.
Like I mentioned, I love sports.
So if you built an app, and
you're using AdMob by Google
to monetize your app, and then
the application-- the adverts
that I would be
receiving are most likely
going to be sports related ads.
So your app that's a
sports app that you
bought AdWords in,
then me as an end user,
I'm going to be
receiving that one.
So if you're building
an app, you'd
want to deliver ads
to your end users
that your end users
will engage with.
You don't want to be obnoxious.
You don't want to give them
ads that they don't care about.
So AdMob, the power and
the technology behind that,
is built into this.
So there's a SDK for
that for Firebase
that could make it very, very
simple for you to do ads.
Video ads, interstitial
ads, banner ads,
all those kind of
things in your apps.
And that's it for this
overview of Firebase.
So thank you so much
for attending [CHINESE].
And I have some time for some
questions if anybody has any.
[APPLAUSE]
I'll also be at the Firebase
booth over in the main floor.
So if you want to come
talk about Firebase.
Do we have a question over here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Firebase Crash Report will
collect in the native crash.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Will
collect the native crash?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, native crash
and the crash in the SO.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
the Android stack,
so the stack that's for
Android, it will collect that.
If it's stuff within
the NDK, right now
it's not a very
detailed list of what
we would indicate has crashed.
AUDIENCE: Will [INAUDIBLE]
be the next release?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
We're working on it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
INTERPRETER: So two questions
about whether Firebase
can be used in China,
because [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right now it's
for international applications.
So I'm not sure of the details
of accessing it within China.
The Firebase
documentation, I believe,
we've just relaunched
in China, and we're
continuing to work on it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Are you talking
about into the
documentation side?
AUDIENCE: No.
The console.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
So the console at the moment, is
for international applications
rather than for domestic
Chinese applications.
So they need-- whatever you do
for international applications
at the moment for it to be able
to access Firebase Console.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: We
hope to improve that.
AUDIENCE: I have four questions.
[INAUDIBLE] service
user [INAUDIBLE]
MongoDB or [INAUDIBLE].
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm sorry.
Can you repeat?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
when could [INAUDIBLE] use
[INAUDIBLE] as the database?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, so
the underlying database?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
It's one of our own.
It's not MongoDB.
It's just something
we built ourselves.
AUDIENCE: So do you have
some material for [INAUDIBLE]
already knows that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I don't
have the details of that.
If you come see me at the
booth and give me your contact
details, I'll have somebody from
the engineering team in Google
send you those details.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: We
have time for one more.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
INTERPRETER: So two questions.
First question is, Firebase
depends on your Google Play
services, Google Play service--
LAURENCE MORONEY: On Android?
INTERPRETER: Yeah, the
Android and so whether he
is able to use in China.
Second question is about,
can I download logs
from the crash reports?
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK I'll
answer the second one first.
The answer is yes.
That was easy.
So for the first part of
it, the Google Play services
binaries, when merging
into the Firebase binaries,
so Google Play
Services as a runtime
is kind of going away
in favor of Firebase.
When that's going to be
available for native apps
in China, for local apps,
I can't say right now.
Do you want to translate?
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
if any other questions,
I'll be over at the
Firebase booth in the expo.
It's all the way down there.
So please come see me.
And thank you very much.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[APPLAUSE]